I don't know when it was but freely
recently you started going with the
jet-black hair
yeah and it looks badass it looks great
you thank you I've decided I want to
stay badass for the rest of my life well
how did this transition happen well it
was really Ryan Murphy's kind of concept
for the last episodes of American Horror
Story last year you look like you know
real badass by Jared and then I had
already shot Big Bang Theory who you
know which was we played me and Teller
played mayim Bialik's parents and we had
already shot the wedding and had my own
gray hair so and then they brought us
back okay we're all your Kathy Bates
were all with you every step of the way
you could you could you could seriously
start reading through the phone book and
we'd be married okay so anyway so then
we had to do when I was shooting
American horror and it had my black hair
I had to go back and do some Big Bang
Theory so they had to make her gray wig
for me so there it was and they popped
the gray wig I mean I was looking in the
rear I thought okay we're not going back
now tell you when I was a kid I I had
you know like orange orange hair and big
freckles when I was a kid and I hated it
and I remember thinking I wish I had
jet-black hair
I want it as a kid that was something
that I wanted and I you were a fan of
Elvis's - a huge fan of Elvis I love and
also any Jack Lord from Hawaii five-o
like anybody who had jet black hair I
remembered I had this I look like a
pumpkin and I would just sit in front of
the TV and go I want to look like that
guy
well have you ever thought about
actually doing it or is it yet you've
got to look now an image I I think if I
dyed my hair black people would just
they wouldn't be me anymore
you know I think people would get upset
and I don't think it would look right it
i I'd like to know if it would because
actually
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
this doesn't work for me I mean this is
fun for now but yeah or like a family of
birds from New Guinea living it didn't
look right you want to try this one on
yeah no you can't okay Annie you go for
it my work for you this is not very
hygienic good yeah no I know now you've
got what I've got
yeah we both have a very large kind of a
Roy Orbison you know a little bit of a
country-western you don't I mean yeah
yeah the ghostly pale high voice
[Laughter]